from the moment we met i was like she's
all right i felt
comfortable
really comfortable with her
i left her a voicemail said hello my
name is chris
um would you like to go on a date
i was watching on a friday night this
episode of the brady bunch where this
cheerleader was so cute she knocked me
out
and then i married her
tell me one two who are you the bears
three four tell me who's going to score
the bears
we met when we were 20 at a hockey game
you had a hockey game he walked by my
seats and had some cocky remarks
everyone's got their price
jt got in contact with jessica biel the
old-fashioned way getting her number
from a friend nick jonas used a more
modern tactic with priyanka well he did
slide into my dm
he was
this tornado that kind of just took over
my life and i just kind of went with it
nick's big brother joe took the same
direct approach with sophie turner after
a little encouragement from mutual
friends three years later the duo
surprised us by eloping with elvis
before their french nuptials the next
month how are you feeling about your
relationship right now it means so much
to have him here it's just like the best
support the best person to calm me down
and keep me calm and if i end up crying
i have a shoulder to cry on so it's good
i'm so happy that he's here
for david beckham it was love at first
sight when he saw victoria in a spice
girls music video a few months later
they flirted at a soccer game she wrote
her number on a train ticket he's my
soul mate and we really support each
other i'm so proud of him
what 13 year old boy didn't have a crush
on jennifer connelly
fellow brit paul bettany first laid eyes
on his future wife in the 1986 film
labyrinth 15 years later they met on the
set of a beautiful mind i remember
saying to myself i've never been
this close to somebody that beautiful
that's the truth i didn't think that
he did get out that guitar
really
yeah he's a very nice voice then there's
zendaya and tom holland some suggest
that parker's powers include the male
spider's ability to hypnotize females
the co-stars have been dodging
relationship rumors since their first
spider-man film in 2017 but photographs
of the duo kissing last summer revealed
that spidey had finally caught zendaya
in his web
i think zendaya just sounds like they're
just showed up
you know we we all work so hard we're
all so you know we're all so close from
that
megan fox and machine gun kelly also
credit set life with bringing them
together you shot only for two days on
the screen um and that's how i met him i
was like
uh uh-oh because i knew i could feel
some wild was gonna happen to me
the self-proclaimed twin flames shared
the screen in midnight in the
switchgrass and the rest quickly
unfolded from there whatever daddy says
i just waited outside on my trailer
steps every day i worked just i had no
glimpse of eye contact and i would just
sit there and like hope
now the love birds are engaged
carrie underwood and mike fisher were
set up on a blind date so were tom brady
and gisele bunchen and prince harry and
meghan markle we were introduced
actually by a mutual friend yes it was
definitely a setup it was a blind date
and here's an interesting one jerry
o'connell literally manifested his
marriage to rebecca romain not to freak
my wife out but i may or may not have
carried a photo of her on my wallet for
10 years
and then here we are we're married i'm
engaged i'm getting married
but one of the sweetest full circle
moments goes to brad paisley who just
couldn't forget seeing kimberly williams
on the big screen and father of the
bride in some weird way i'm the only guy
that
sat in that theater and said
i'm going to marry that girl
and really did
that sounds more like a stalker
situation than i knew um
can you believe that and here's another
thing that's hard to believe dak shepard
and kristen bell might hail from the
same part of michigan but it took moving
to la for them to finally meet he also
told me that your
recollection of your first meeting is
incorrect he said that
you did not he did not ask for the gum
in your mouth he asked you if you had
gum and you said
i don't have gum only this only this and
then he took it out of my hand that is
true despite their sticky situation dax
got the frozen star's number from a
mutual friend and the rest is history
he's really funny we have a good time
together he's just really sweet he's a
good kid he's a good part and i love him
long before justin and hailey bieber
said i do too forever they were hanging
out as family friends it's thanks to
this party trick that their friendship
turned romantic years later last time i
was here i opened a corona bottle with
my teeth and
the next morning
after the interview had aired i got
a certain phone call from a certain
someone
and it was a little like hey how are you
i saw you on jimmy fallon last night you
were looking really good
i loved that trick that you did i had no
idea that you can do that it was so cool
cut two
i'm now married to that certain
[Applause]
[Music]
you